et on aura l'occasion d'évoquer avec lui
bien sûr le souvenir de son frère Malik
sur la ligne dérivée Hugo ou la partager
sa victoire avec son petit frère décédé
en 2012 heurté par un chauffard où il
voulait à tout prix remporter cette
année une étape du Tour pour son frère
et pour lui ça a été gagné
une course avant aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui je gagne
complètement fou mais
on le fait depuis je suis sûr que mon
frère m'aidait à 31 ans Hugo ou les deux
premiers québécois a remporté une étape
du Tour de France le deuxième canadien
34 ans après Steve Bauer Steve Bauer
aujourd'hui le directeur sportif de
l'équipe d'Hugo ou les deux maïkon Woods
Israël première Tech qui appartient à
l'homme d'affaires israélo-canadiens
Silvan Adams troisième mardi le
québécois s'est adjugé en solitaire la
16e étape disputée à la Porte des
Pyrénées
excellent rouleur Hugo houle s'est porté
en tête au 140 km il a ensuite avalé
seul en tête le dernier mur de l'État 9
km à 8 %
Woods a fait son travail d'équipier à la
perfection pour protéger l'avance du
Québec
dans la voiture de l'équipe Steve Bauer
a suivi avec émotion les derniers
maîtres du rouleur de 31 ans
a finalement terminé 3e au sein d'un
petit groupe à 70 secondes de son
coéquipier qu'il attendait pour partager
son émotion
[Musique]
la prêt spécialisée française a qualifié
de remarquable la performance du goal
qui a d'ailleurs remporté le prix de la
combativité ici Philippe Crépeau
Radio-Canada Montréal